welcome to star talk
your place in the universe where science
and pop culture collide
star talk begins
right now
[Music]
star trek
town hall
the topic is food
food the science and technology of food
on earth and in space i want to first
introduce my co-host this evening you
all remember him from comedy central
jordan klepper jordan come on out hey
everybody
hello everybody
good to be here
right good to be here
we got you and you've you've posted uh
clapper hosted the well-named clepper on
comedy creative name the most creative
name yes but it's a series of
documentaries where you're exploring i
explore this in america
it turns out this is a strange country
we live in yeah so i went out there i
talked to people yeah you got to meet
these people neil they're very strange
so i've been lucky enough to meet a lot
of them yes jordan clipper so
there we go
all right so also joining us in addition
to
the inimitable jordan klepper is
flavor scientist
and food chemist dr arielle johnson dr
johnson come on out
hi
thanks
jordan
you have a phd in viticulture and
and knowledge enology yeah at
uc davis that's that's where i went
isn't that just code for wine
a lot of wine we actually
did a lot of studies of different
beverages so there's some gin some
tequila a little bit of beverages yes
beverages and to be fair neal i have a
doctorate in scotch
and our feature guest this evening
is the one and only
alton brown alton brown come on out
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so let me fill in some of this bio
so
you hang tight for a minute you you were
like phd oh [ __ ] really
you're a phd advisor
to the
premier restaurant noma in denmark yes
that's like one of the most premier
restaurants ever it did win best
restaurant in the world a few times yeah
under your watch
sometimes
that that's amazing so this is a job
it is a job that i
kind of invented um when i was doing
research in grad school i went over
there to see what they were up to and
write some papers and then i was like
hey i'm available why don't you guys
hire me because we're having such a
great great week
i want that job right
and your medal
[Laughter]
officer on a show called good eats i
heard about that
i heard about that
that that there's a show that even has
somebody called a science officer
good each yeah
14 years on food network good evening um
[Applause]
that was the that was the original run
we actually just crossed 20 this year oh
can i can i ask her a quick question
where is flavor rama in juxtaposition to
flavor town
[Laughter]
are they close to each other they are
close to each other but but flavorama
has much better urban planning and an
actual like sewer system there you go
there you go
cool
we have you on this show because you're
not just celebrity chef you have made it
a career to juxtapose to cross-pollinate
the fruits of science
and its research into the food you
prepare yes sir this is an important
place to be as we go forward in this
world i believe that it is so so what
intrigued me about the two of you
especially since she's on your staff
consulting
flavoramaist
okay this means
sort of on the staff
so so you come to science from food and
she comes to food from science could you
both share with me how you how that what
that trajectory was
you first oh for me um
well i was super interested in food as a
kid um to the point where like my
grandmother was a really good cook and
i'd go over to her house and she had
this like amazing cookbook collection
and sometimes i would just like get on
the floor and read them for hours um and
i'd cook a lot um
then when i was like getting into
getting like a bachelor's degree uh
it turned out you could do food and
science together it's a bachelor's
degree no i was doing a bachelor's
degree in chemistry so i was super
interested in chemistry you're
fundamentally a chemist i am yeah all of
my formal training is in chemistry okay
yeah um
it turned out that chefs were interested
in science and scientists were
interested in working with chefs so i
did some of that here at nyu and then um
found a graduate program that would let
me continue so
davis uc davis ended up out west
so alton how did you get to science from
food
um i got to science from food by
realizing that i wasn't a very good cook
that's how you got into comedy
i had uh left wait you have a show on
food network yeah i do and you just said
yeah you're not a good cook well i used
to i'm better
it got better
it got better but when i went off to
culinary school i changed careers
because i wanted to make a food show and
i got off to culinary school and
realized holy crap i'm actually not very
good at this but what i figured out is
that if i could understand the science
of what was going on in the food i could
be a better cook and so that was the
tact that i that i took with my show
which is that if we all just understand
what it is the food freaking wants
we can make it better and the answer to
that is almost always science so you're
saying
not to put words in your mouth but
anyone in the kitchen can become a
better scientist
with a dose of science literacy added to
it
[Music]
yes but they don't necessarily have to
you can become a better cook through
science you could definitely become a
better scientist through cooking
definitely um but i don't think that you
have to have science there are people
that are just great cooks
i'm not that well that's not what i ask
you get a great cook now you add some
science to their great cooking does the
cooking get better
it can i'm not going to say unilaterally
that it will because some people don't
care nor should they because they're
cultural cooks maybe and they they're
they're they're cooking out of
traditions they don't have to understand
what's going on i trained under some
really great french chefs all they had
to do was scream really
loud and the food was delicious
that is a science yeah she's like an
idiot
that's part of the science
science of management but it i i do i do
think that at least for me and i think
for for
american culture certainly where we are
is is that if if you are willing to
learn some science it will make you a
better cook is that answering your
question yeah so you advise noma
restaurant head of r d the idea that a
restaurant would have an r d head that
that tickles me and but what it
particularly intrigues me is that this
is in denmark
and that restaurant
is committed to
local ingredients
yeah so like so doesn't that greatly
limit what you can create
it is a huge and sometimes terrifying
limitation um i know the first year that
they opened this is before i got there
they're like great we're going gonna use
seasonal nordic produce um and it was
november and their their vegetable
supplier came to the back door and was
like great here's your seasonal nordic
produce and it was like three beets and
a carrot
um
but
in many creative pursuits in the arts i
think that
creative constraints really help you be
more creative and so in that case the
constraint of having to source
ingredients from the nordic region the
scandinavian region which is very cold
has a very short growing season not a
lot of sunlight there's no citrus there
either there's no citrus no citrus no
olive oil um great dairy but like a lot
of fruits don't grow there there's no
wine that really grows there other than
that it's a great
get me out of play
they have the finest reindeer piss
you can actually get the reindeer moths
from the inside of the reindeers uh no
stop that scent where where no no stop
that sentence
get flavor from the inside of the
reindeers i don't want to hear the end
of that scent
but yeah so lemons don't grow in denmark
so like but just to be clear you just
affirm that reindeers do exist reindeers
exist they're a real thing okay i just
want to be clear
and something comes out of them
various things come out of them
there's many gastronomic i've never seen
mark i am never i'm never going
so you're saying that you you what you
would do is
is substitute what might be familiar
uh flavors with something else that
approximates it so any good examples um
well actually one thing so like cooking
tends to be better if you have some
acidity um it just like brightens up all
the flavors and a lot of chefs like to
use lemons for that if you don't have
access to lemons it turns out that the
uh
well the
native
european forest ant formica roofa
they're called formeka because they
produce a lot of formic acid so these
are actually like tangy ants
so by going into the forest you know
looking for
mushrooms or uh berries or flower petals
you start tasting these ants and you're
like wow these are you start tasting
wait wait wait wait wait
she just worked at a zoo
[Laughter]
you go
you rummage the forest floor
for ants
taste them to see if they will work in
this world-class restaurant i have done
that yes
um so it turns out these ants are very
acidic um we have we have at noma we had
friends that were chefs in other places
in the world like brazil who were
experimenting with ants because it's no
like the native amazonian cuisine uses
ants um so we're like well why not try
these ants that are swarming all over us
um
and it turns out
so ants are very acidic so you can make
this like quite acidic and refreshing
ant paste that we put on like a juniper
and blueberry it was good it was really
good um jordan she used the word
refreshing yeah
but also it turns out that um
so ants have a lot of pheromones they
use chemicals to signal with each other
so they have like what's called a
chemical ecology and we were you know we
were tasting these ants and like yes
but it turns out a lot of the chemicals
that they use to communicate with each
other are some of the same
uh volatile flavor molecules that are in
herbs and flowers and uh other tasty
plants is this the foundation of
molecular gastronomy i've heard that
term and frankly i never really
understood what it meant i think a lot
of people don't understand what that's
yeah yeah um so
some some people some like journalists
and stuff attach molecular gastronomy to
certain styles of cooking technically
speaking molecular gastronomy is a field
of study
um the
basically paying attention to
molecularly the chemistry of everything
that happens in food and cuisine so in
cooking and growing food
so it's related to food science but so
you think about the difference between
taste and smell oh yeah all the time so
which can you
and flavor what can you judge is there
one more important than the other
it is there
uh how much of our
dna
gets directed to
what can you tell us i can tell you a
lot about that actually so uh although
when we like eat something tasty and we
experience the flavor we think we feel
like that's happening in the mouth and
is all taste actually a huge amount of
flavor comes from smell um there's a
process called retro nasal olfaction um
retronasal olfaction
so that's in contrast to orthonasal
olfaction of course um of course we all
knew that right right yeah
i think that's a cocktail up on 43.
a rectal nasal old-fashioned
i had one of those invasive
sounds like college
[Laughter]
um
orthonasal olfaction is sniffing it's
when you smell things
smell has one syllable last i checked
we can't really write in a paper like
today this paper is about and there's
the problem with that
it's all we really need all right so
what happens chemically when we taste
something so when we taste or when we
smell something there's molecules in
your food um it's full of molecules it's
made of molecules get some fresh stuff
no with without molecules there is no
food okay well let's ask all of it's
smaller
molecules all the way down
um some of my best friends are made of
molecules okay
so
that's the bumper sticker right there
um
so
you eat food the food has a bunch of
molecules um some of them can bind to
receptor proteins uh these are proteins
expressed on the outside of cells in our
tongue and in our nasal cavity so like
the tongue
um and the nasal cavity which i can't
show you but it's this little patch of
you actually stick stuck out your tongue
to tell us what your tongue is yeah
nasal olfactory whatever you just said
that and kept moving in the sentence
he's got i mean i have i have the tongue
demo already i i don't have to crack
open your skull and show this little
patch and then you'd be dead of uh of
the olfactory epithelium um so uh
molecules in the food we have we have uh
taste receptors but we also have
um the largest
family of genes in our genome is devoted
to smell so this is approximately 400
different genes um
it's about two percent of our genome so
it's a huge amount of genetic
information it's like roughly the same
amount of genetic information that
separates humans from our closest
primate
relatives and is this because it's more
important to smell the bear than to
taste the bear
well usually with um with tastes you
have sweet sour salty bitter umami and
then the sort of deep scientific
research is trying to find more um so
cheetos this is the cheeto sensor yeah
i'm with you it's better to smell the
bear before you're close enough to taste
it well yes that's the point i agree 100
on that one so the reason i bring up
orthonasal olfaction and retro nasal
effect again is because smell plays two
roles for us and for a lot of animals so
there is the um sniffing in roll the
orthonasal roll so that's smelling the
bear before we get there
um and then once you let's say
fight with the bear and
conquer the bear and roast the bear um
if you're if you're eating the banana
what are you doing in denmark
[Laughter]
when you have food in your mouth you're
also experiencing smell so it has this
dual role of sniffing things out in the
environment but also giving you this
rich sensory experience while you're
eating while now could given all that
you know about receptors the shapes of
molecules as they enter our head
can you imagine either you or a future
ai
inventing a whole new
smell or a whole new
flavor
is that a possible future
goal
of what you do well interestingly so the
human sense of smell is very flexible so
we have about 400 different receptors
but we can smell
thousands upon thousands maybe hundreds
of thousands of different odor molecules
so through
what we call combinatorial coding
um
uh you're able to kind of rather than um
just picking out one particular molecule
you get like a pattern for each type of
molecule so actually like quite
frequently the flavor industry will
synthesize a new molecule that has never
existed in nature before but we are able
to smell it okay so you can have a new
smell that's a combination of other
smells that doesn't exist itself yeah or
the uh
the pattern that it makes in the brain
um actually activates different like
memory associations so if if like you
know this this part hanging off the
molecule kind of reminds me of lavender
and this part of the molecule this is
your brain shocking kind of activates
the like leather memory oh my god it's
my grandma
that's what it smells like smells like
grandmother
so alton
in principle you don't have to be in her
lab to come up with some truly
innovative new flavor you you're you're
the guy
you're like you you are food geek
in the food universe but but i'm not
inventing new flavors i mean she's
talking about actually inventing
something that doesn't exist that you
wouldn't be able to all right only your
olympic system would be i gotta figure
that out you combine other flavors in
ways no one had previously dreamt of
into a new culinary masterpiece
does he has he met me
[Laughter]
what i try to do is to make something
taste more like what you think it ought
to taste like so
everybody knows
in their head what mac and cheese ought
to be like oh yeah
right
but when you make your own mac and
cheese it very often does not
reflect
that sense so what i try to do is to to
to make food taste more like the thing
you thought it ought to taste like and
sometimes that involves adding things
that you didn't know would go in there
so very often that's that is waking up
one flavor by supporting it with another
so i might go into macaroni and cheese
and i might put a little bit of nutmeg
in there
uh because i know how that supports
certain cheese aromas
um and i do know that it's that's why
they kind of put that in lasagna yes
they'll put a little just a little in
bachelor sauce because bachelor's one of
the binders but see his food and this is
something aaron allen aaronov talked
about you said melchizedek
that's what i was making i didn't know
that well in lasagna there's often a
white sauce that is what the french
would call bachelor but i why are the
french making lasagna
i'm sorry i didn't i i
didn't mean to blow a gaffer because
when it comes to cooking the french do
whatever they want to do
well the point is is when you when you
go to eat very often the aroma gets to
your nose long before the food gets so
we eat with our eyes then we eat with
our nose and then it finally actually
gets into our mouth well there's a lot
of things that we can do with with herbs
and spices they're actually a lot more
about making that that connection first
because then you're like oh my god i'm
home you know or oh my gosh i'm loved
because some of us grew up associating
love with
noodles
[Laughter]
but sometimes it's it's turning around
and saying and this is something that
because i've read a lot of ariel's work
is that you you all of a sudden realize
okay
this this compound in this food would
actually taste more like itself
if we put this in it but yet this is not
something that you would normally
associate
okay for instance i can make chicken
soup taste
hella more like chicken by using misoo
paste in it not enough so that you would
recognize that it's there
okay and there are a lot of ways to play
that game in in the food world back me
up so
so this is you experimenting in the
kitchen absolutely but but how do you
tap ariel's expertise okay when you're
in the kitchen and you're left alone in
the kitchen how do you grab well the
number one way that i tap her knowledge
is when a word has more than five
syllables
i call up ariel i say what the hell is
that
and then she answers with a bunch of
other five-syllable words that i still
can't understand because you have a
look-up chart which we still have just
have a look-up chart um but but a lot of
time it's it's coming to when when i
read um really great chemistry some of
it's just understanding how things work
but but some of it is then understanding
how we can take our knowledge and
especially now in a culture we have more
foodstuffs available to us than any
culture ever in the history of mankind
true yes yeah more than kings and queens
sure
yeah i guess
look
10 years ago on tv
there were a whole bunch of things i
couldn't do that i can do now because
you can simply order things by going
like this
okay so you know 10 years ago we weren't
using aleppo pepper and dishes for home
cooks because they couldn't get it right
today we go like this as we have more
and more stuff available to us we've got
to figure out well how do we how do we
use this to still make food that we want
to eat now she works with people that
are actually inventing new foods and new
flavors i just want to make the macaroni
and cheese better
all right but
often when we think of sort of food
experiments any normal person would
wonder whether you guys in the kitchen
are going to somehow take our palate
to the limit
so i just want to know is there some
limit beyond which you would not
try
some combination of ingredients short of
it being actual poison i'm just
wondering is there or is anything
poison's a funny thing because no it's
not a funny thing not very funny i'm
backing up nail on this because it's not
very funny
we we have very strong taste receptors
for astringency do we not and bitterness
and bitterness greatly because it keeps
us from eating poison and yet we teach
ourselves
to drink things like coffee and scotch
which ought to be poison but they're not
so some of it's training some of its
acclimation cultural acclimation wait
wait if that flavor is associated with
things that will kill you yes then it's
just kind of by accident that you're
still alive if you like this flavor of
bitter
you just yes yes okay
i mean at some point somebody had to eat
that first oyster
or somebody had to
sniff that first band-aid i don't know
i mean it's a dangerous world out there
somebody had to pluck that chicory from
the field and be like i need that and
chicory is the perfect or
the first uh rhubarb where they figured
out oh the last five people who ate this
died
i'm gonna cook it
all right so
so i bet jordan's with me on this if the
last four people died
i'm not cooking it yeah i'm like i'm i'm
like you know what we don't need to eat
roomba
at all
what's this mac and cheese thing you're
talking about yeah not even in a pie
yeah but we don't humans don't do that
we do not do that dead humans are going
back
we're so curious we see that stack of
bodies and we're like no i can do it
[Laughter]
what you need is a bunch of archaic frat
boys around daring each other to eat
things so one of them will figure out
mushrooms would be the perfect example
try this one tastes good the other made
you trip the other dissolved your liver
into a puddle
do you learn real quick you know is this
why people go to this restaurant you
work there
[Laughter]
is there just a pile of bodies outside
and being like this is a good restaurant
you got to try it well
no reservation
just dragging the people out i just we
would
like mushrooms that we had like not a
really good
botanical and ethnobotanical idea of
what was safe and we would also never
feed anything to a customer that we
hadn't eaten ourselves first good
possibility sure
so if everybody in the kitchen is dead
shake shack
there were episodes of um one of one of
my colleagues trying out a new mushroom
and uh you know having to run to puke in
the dumpster before he had to go into
service and then we never served that
mushroom um but
that's no human has ever known
every customer has ever gotten ariel
what are you saying
that
your own staff and then the occasional
customer no are the experimental
playground of your culinary
exploits
welcome to flavorama everybody
good luck
should we call you doctor flavor oh yeah
you can if you want evil
evil evil doctor flavor evil evil flavor
you have a server who comes over and
then a priest comes over after the man
well no i mean in in all seriousness for
for
any of the like quote-unquote novel
things that are happening at these
restaurants you're usually
you're trying out new things but you're
drawing on
either validated scientific research or
like long histories of of safe
techniques so like for some ingredients
there are no no safe way to eat them or
it's you can eat them but only once
uh
and for some things there's there's
that's called poison we have a word for
that yes there's techniques that we know
we have to have to use for them um so
uh
yeah no there's a lot of uh safety and
concern over safety i have one note
i've been known about before any
customers i think most people don't know
that the common ancestor between animals
and mushrooms
separated in the tree of life later
than that common ancestor and that which
produced green plants separated so that
humans and mushrooms are more
genetically alike than either humans or
mushrooms are to green plants so that
last pizza you ate you're an incestuous
bastard
[Music]
[Applause]
i think the word you're looking for is
cannibalism
[Laughter]
have i not been having sex this whole
[Laughter]
talking about time this whole time right
wait what's happening here
just an arrow because we'll only have
you for a few more minutes because we're
going to swap you out with yet another
person on stage here
much like your restaurant
a couple of things are there any
obvious challenges that you see in this
moment for the future of cooking i want
to ask both of you that
um
this is something if we only had a lot
of we could only do that just some
something that is on the horizon that's
in the lab that's going to show up soon
what might that be
oh i would say if we only had
governments that understood the global
warming's happening and if we don't do
something
alton that's in our third segment today
sorry i
you provided the segway you get dock to
turn ariel some of some of the stuff
that i'm most excited about at the
intersection of food and science right
now has to do with um plant breeding and
seed breeding so for a very long time um
plants have been especially in the u.s
bred for uniformity for yield and for
ability so
if you hear your grandmother saying like
oh the tomatoes don't taste like when i
was a little girl like that's because
they don't they have lost flavor in the
process um
turns out it's actually very simple to
to breed plants for flavor just not a
lot of people are doing it so there's
some very cool projects especially out
on the west coast university of oregon
university of washington the bread lab
is one of them
where they are growing vegetables and
grains and
things like wheat and barley to be
extremely flavorful and cook very well
so
that i think is one of the most exciting
combinations of
food and science to be
hitting the grocery stores sometime soon
but will it be shippable and will it be
packageable because that's how we got to
flavorless tomatoes to start with right
but if in uniformity and beautiful and
but if you can breed tomatoes to grow
well in specific regions or then you'll
have to ship them and then you don't
have to zip them down you grow that gets
you on that one yeah definitely face
palm on that one
there's a um there's a barley project in
oregon called the multi-barley project
and this is a very biodiverse strain of
barley you can grow it in many places
and each place will express a different
sort of phenotype and flavor
so terroir you get a different terroir
very nice the terroir very wine word
there tel
tala
well we're going to end this segment and
we're going to get ready for the next
segment which is going to be all about
food in space when stark talk continues
yeah
and
dr ariel thank you for coming thank you
thank you so much
star talk segment two welcome back town
hall
we are live from town hall in new york
city i'm with my comedic co-host jordan
klepper hey everybody
special guest alton brown
and in this segment we're going to talk
about food in space i need an expert on
that and we got her now joining us is
nasa food scientist dr grace douglas
great come on out
okay thank you
grace is the lead scientist in nasa's
advanced food technology research effort
thanks for coming up from houston to be
in new york for this absolutely i'm a
little afraid to ask you what you're
holding in your arms there some snacks
for you snacks
they look
nasty nasty
we'll talk a little bit more about those
a little later so tell us what is the
advanced technology food project at nasa
so basically we have a food system that
works on the international space station
but we know that there are shortfalls
and we need to get to
long duration space exploration missions
and so in advanced food technology we
do research on foods we do research on
how to fit in the very very small
resources that are provided on missions
and we also do research on
how we're actually
promoting crew health and performance so
making sure that the food can actually
do that
so
i i'm curious about something when we
think of nasa we think of rockets and
things hardly ever do we think that
there are people in nasa trying to keep
the astronauts alive and so you're in
that division right and of course the
the
the astronaut program is based in
houston so it would make sense that the
food research is there as well yeah so
so you've got um
law the
so specifically you focus on how food
tastes or just whether it goes bad or
not
we have to focus on every part of it
which the
key components of it are the safety
nutrition and flavor because
food for the international space station
actually needs an 18-year shelf life at
a minimum and it's better if it's longer
18 years 18 months 18 months 18 months
okay
sorry that's still a long amount of time
oh that's my oh okay yes
this turkey sandwich will last don't
worry about it i thought he's in 18
years it's an 18-month turkey sandwich
five
that's true jordan both of those don't
sound good they don't sound
super tasty okay
wait so what is non-safe food well that
would be food so we process our foods to
make them safe we have freeze-dried
foods so microorganisms can't grow in
there and we have
retort thermal stabilized foods which is
basically canned foods except we use a
pouch so that's the silver pouched item
and that one nope the other this one yes
so this is uh basically it's similar to
what the military uses but it's
lightweight so we can get it up into
space
mass and volume are huge considerations
for spaceflight so the pouch is
lightweight
yes the pouch is lightweight this is a
canned food and a pouch basically and so
we have to process this is processed to
commercial sterility just like canned
foods in the grocery store yummy
sterility
so we don't microorganisms are your
enemy
for safe food yes over time when you
have to store it for that amount of time
and we have no refrigerators no freezers
and the possibility that we still won't
have those going on a mars mission where
the shelf life will need to be five
years at that point
that's enough for a return trip yes
right right so
so wait
you didn't you haven't yet talked about
flavor yes just whether the thing
whether it's bad for you three points
the first is safety the second is
nutrition and the third is acceptability
and that's in total
so how about potato chips
well so potato chips are interesting you
can send them but they often have a lot
of crumbs
and so crunchy that causes a problem in
microgravity
um so okay so safety has two meanings
then yes it does that's that's very true
will it kill you
because you it it i don't know it floats
into your nose or something or or
whether it's whether there's some
microorganism that'll give you a stomach
virus or something or whatever so a lot
of foods like potato chips are shelf
stable so they will last they will tend
to go rancid over time you'll get some
off flavors they won't taste as good and
the food definitely needs to taste good
if it doesn't taste good enough the crew
doesn't want to eat enough of it or
choose those foods and then they can
lose weight they can lose bone mass and
muscle mass and so
we really have to provide food that they
choose to eat that they want to eat and
so there
there's a common assumption that high
performing individuals like astronauts
will eat whatever you tell them to eat
just to get the mission accomplished
basically we could give them vitamin
pills we could give them
protein shakes they'll get it done which
actually those things are not that
healthy but they will um
they're
they're actually just like us on earth
and they really want good food
nutritious food and food becomes very
important and isolation and confinement
we i hear that astronauts might lose
their
sense of taste in zero g or in space is
that true
what what is meant by that
so some astronauts come back and say the
food tasted different or they didn't
taste it as much as they would on earth
and so the intensity of it maybe
something's going on right but there are
other astronauts who come back and say
they didn't notice a difference and
there's several things that could
possibly be impacting that so
there's a fluid shift towards their head
when they're in microgravity and so that
can give them the sensation like when
you have a cold so you wouldn't taste
things as well also
everything they're eating is out of a
package and they're not cooking it's
just heat and add water so they're
getting packaged foods in and out
without cooking and then the aroma
doesn't rise in microgravity it just
dissipates and there's also a lot of
competing aromas on the international
space station if you ever live in an
enclosed environment with five other
people so
now that's the word of roma but you
really mean stank
you said aroma but you mean like b.o
they're smelly there can be bad smells
over time if you're in an enclosed
environment with a lot of other people
really is there any kind of a is there
any kind of a food space race like are
the russians developing flavors that are
more intense than american flavors is
there competition in that how are we
doing are we gonna win
who's got jambalaya is that on our side
i would think that the chinese would
actually have this
because of their because of their their
spice range and because the use of
things like szechuan peppercorns and
whatnot they would those would be very
opening of the head kind of uh kind of
flavors russians
yeah yep
though vodka so grace would you
one day call up alton and say help me
out here because my astronauts are about
to mutiny
well they did
emeril lagasse bam uh sent food up to
was that that was his space station
right yeah he he helped work on a few
formulations
um so just to be clear when he says bam
isn't he always putting garlic into his
food no
no
it's anything he wanted
bam bam
okay
just checking you guys remember bam
right
bam formulation
the problem is in space like bam what
the hell
how did that hear the jambalaya went
over well
uh so actually i think we might have a i
i don't know if i brought that one out
but i think it's out there the spicy
green beans it's in the white package
over there yes this is the tomatoes
that he helped this is spicy green beans
bam
no i'm not going no yes no neil should
eat that right now
right now
let let's just be clear
uh let's just be clear grace you brought
these because these foods are expired
from yourselves right here good till
5027.
how important is variety
variety is actually don't answer that
until he eats those green dates
look at that look at that move on
they're actually freeze-dried so i don't
know how easy it would be to eat those
but these here
[Laughter]
so
this this
tomato and artichoke i recognize it from
here you read the package
so
what kind of variety
is
is offered
because i think a lot about suppose i
only could eat one food on a mars
mission what food would that be i'll
tell you what that food is in a minute
but after you eat the cream no no
so
tell me about variety
you are not going to do it are you
you are not gonna do it
come on phil they want you to eat them
[ __ ]
yeah
look at this all right
help help there's another packet inside
of the bracket
oh none for me damn
okay how do i put water
[Laughter]
what if i found something to cut the end
off could we just you know oh you
probably i'll go find some scissors
that's going to be okay you're going to
get your beans don't worry it's
so was this in a
in a opaque packet to prevent light from
getting it because clearly it's
shrink-wrapped or freeze-dried
shrink-wrapped so now air is not going
to get in that reduces oxygen but does
is light also damaging to this for
certain vitamins light can be damaging
oxygen and moisture and that package
does not protect from those things so we
do add the aluminum foil layer to get
along i forget nutrients of course yes
uh vitamins are not all stable under all
situations right especially vitamin c
it's very very unstable and that's why
scurvy was so prevalent in the history
of
exploration before space flight
how's scurvy doing up there on the
international space station right now
we've got that thing covered right
for the international space station yes
not yet from ours though
are you dealing with are you getting a
lot of feedback from astronauts i got to
imagine astronauts aren't the easiest
people to work with as far as taste
testers go is that is that in and of
itself hazardous
don't
pay no attention to that
that that man struggling to open a
package over there
is this this is reason what
[Applause]
so technically this is what we call
unearth a corkscrew but
here i don't want you i need you to open
my head all right
bam
shitty porsche so it takes like 10
minutes to rehydrate with hot water
i think it takes an hour to rehydrate it
no it's going to be fine that's in hot
water
and
all right here we go
wait wait here actually doesn't smell
too bad
wait wait wait wait jordan smell it
this is uh
it doesn't smell too bad there's nothing
yes
it smells like it like a like a like a
a thai
uh coconut soup
okay that's enough
i'm a professional i know
all right well let's just hydrate how
much in cold water we'll let this
hydrate well yeah we'll let that hydrate
for a minute but we're not going to
forget
so what so if i'm a typical astronaut in
the american sector of the space station
how many options am i going to have for
dinner
well we have about 200 different
foods and beverages on our standard menu
and then they can supplement that on the
international space station with some
preference foods
that we send specially for each crew and
that sounds like a lot perhaps but if
you were to talk to the people next to
you and ask them what they ate for lunch
it's probably very different than what
you ate there's a lot of variety here on
earth we take that for granted and it's
also important for crew to get variety
they say they really love getting choice
in their food system that helps keep
them eating enough so that they don't
lose weight they don't lose body mass
and muscle mass and um bone mass so
those things are very very important to
have the variety and and honestly as we
go towards mars it's going to be much
more difficult to provide that both
because we don't have a current food
system with that shelf life although we
are working on those challenges and
because
um
we might even pre-position food ahead of
a crew
which makes it very hard on a supply
chip yes yes so i mean mars is really
far away i mean you can explain probably
why why we can't send resupply once we
go to mars yeah because you're not in
phase with the position of the planets
in order you're better off sending food
up first yes in another phasing of where
mars and earth are in their orbit with
respect to each other then how long
would you have to wait between sending
food up and sending it right so every 26
months mars and earth are aligned so
that you can go there in nine months but
once you get there you have to wait
again until they realign in order to
send another supply so what you could do
is send a supply before it or after it
um so that they don't have to try to
make food while they're there but yeah
there's a time delay for that to happen
do you mean grow potatoes in poop neil
that's
we'll get there
um is there is there one food
is there one food that is perfectly
nutritious so that if you ate it you
wouldn't have to eat any other kind of
food why wouldn't that be that new
product soylent how about that well
it might be it might be swelling any
food that's designed and i'm sure that
you guys have tested just about
everything by the way are m ms really
like cigarettes in prison on the space
station
because i read that m ms are like where
do the m m's man i want my m m's because
they float around and you go up and it's
on the space station yeah
i'm not lying am i m m's on iss are the
same as cigarettes and prisons yes
or coffee because they don't let you
have cigarettes or prison or it's true
though wouldn't it well they actually
get coffee that they want on the
international space station they can
have it with milk and sugar or well kona
coffee with cream and sugar
whoa that's good so is there so other
than uh soil is there there is one for
instance if you were to tell me you
gotta go right now and you can only have
one food to live on i would probably say
quinoa
i ain't going into space
no i know the perfect food i don't i
don't think i asked you i know the
perfect food what is it new york pizza
you give me
i i thought this through
if you put me on a mission tomorrow and
i had only one food it would be new york
pizza and like uh that's one that hang
on and a strawberry milkshake
that's two yes i would i would i could
eat that every day for five years and in
about a month how do you think you'd
feel
you'd be like hey hey hey
[Applause]
this hat shorty again wait wait wait so
i don't care what you say because i got
bastard nobody can heal you
first i'm in new york city
right now
second
i have proof that pizza's the best thing
yes i have let's go to the videotape
here we go
from the iss
[Applause]
so i don't mean to brag but now you got
it man i got you on that one
got you on that one so
so
let me ask you another kind of question
there's food as nutrition but sometimes
you want space to feel like home if you
might be homesick especially on a long
mission you're not just far away from
home you're far away from your planet as
it recedes in space alton you you don't
you specialize in like
homey taste
uh not only that i i think that ma'am
and you can obviously speak to to those
those flavors i think there's actually
something to be said for the actual
cooking process itself as well oh the
ritual the actual rich they ritualized
the pizza here that was a whole family
affair
let's face it that was like the most
instagramable of all moments you know
hey if i had zero gravity i could do
pizza too um
but sure there are flavors of home
they're they're and i'm sure that you
guys spend a lot of time trying to hit
on what is going to make people feel
like they're still connected without
making them blubber like crybabies that
mommy's gone i mean because there's
there's
homesickness is a weird thing and it's
got you know there's so much different
emotions tied up in food and as people
get further further away say going to
mars
at what point does the power of of of of
what food can do to people's emotional
mindsets
becomes something that we've never even
thought about you guys have got to be
studying that what how do you even go
about studying that sorry i had to ask
you on you want to roll it i want to
know i shut up yeah i'm just really
curious because i know here on this
planet even though i asked you that
question well i pass it on to her that's
fine because she's going to have the
answer that i want at least how do you
how do you figure that out well that's
actually a very complicated question um
because like you just mentioned you like
pizza everyone wants something different
and there is no perfect food so you have
to eat a wide variety just to get all
your nutrients and we have to be able to
provide choice
so that people can get all those
nutrients like fruits and vegetables
actually have thousands of
phytochemicals we don't even know what
they all are and how they're interacting
with our bodies with our microbiomes
with our gut brain axis and impacting
how we think and how we feel and all of
those things are happening just but just
to be clear what you just referenced
there in those few sentences isn't that
like newly emergent understanding of the
role of the microbiome within our body
yes we think we just eat food and it
comes out but there's like
countless microorganisms
doing our bidding for us in our
digestive tract what
[Laughter]
make it sound like game of thrones is
going on outside
i'm doing my bidding
take a knee
[Laughter]
so
so but but to the point of the question
there's all of this going on but there's
certain foods certain rituals
that we associate with home right that
could serve our psychological state
um
mightily so how much thinking do you
guys do about this so we think about
that whenever we're developing new foods
but the goal really is to provide a
variety because we have to be able to
meet the needs of many different people
and their captive audience so once they
go into space flight we can't send
anything else so it's not like going to
the grocery store and you can pick what
you want that day so they have to be
able to find stuff that's there that
they want to eat every day which is its
own challenge and food that does give
them comfort and
we have a lot of crew come back and tell
us that food became so important in
space flight they didn't realize how
important it was going to become
what about the ritual part as that's not
only as alton describes because i mean
almost any movie the most
tense intricate or personal part is when
everyone is around a table eating food
like an alien
i wasn't really thinking about that
but sure okay
so
so the the dinner table you know we we
mock what happens at thanksgiving when
weird uncles come by and ants with
different political views than you have
um
so we mock that but in fact the food is
what got everyone together
it didn't even matter that it's a
holiday called thanksgiving it's a
holiday where food is front and center
and as as alton has has persistently
described this this is a this is a
taproot ritual that we have as a species
so in space are there ways that these
other rituals fold into just even the
preparation and eating of food
well we do provide time for them to eat
together and so usually a lot of crews
try they get to do this at their own
discretion so a lot of crews try to find
time every day or at least every week to
have a meal together for that very
reason and they find it built it helps
build cohesion it does stimulate
conversation especially when you have
international crews and they can share
international foods at that point too
because
the the russians have a russian food
system and the u.s side has a u.s food
system and then when we have uh crew
from europe or canada um or jaxa the
japanese space agency they will bring
some of their own foods and so there's a
lot of camaraderie around that and that
is incredibly important and something
that we definitely have to consider as
we go into exploration how to stabilize
those foods too so that they can
continue and there's also water supply
because you can't unless you last sue a
comet the water you bring has to be
recycled
most of the water on iss is recycled so
should we ask further about that or just
leave it right should we just jordan
should we i'd like to know a little bit
i mean the first thing yeah the first
thing you have to get off the table is
do you drink your own pee then it's like
are you guys eating together what do you
cook
[Laughter]
every first question about a space
station is like urine you're drinking it
okay
now how are you doing how's your family
uh your pe your pee is not the only
body fluid where you can recover water
just to be clear
oh i'm just well there's your sweat
there's right there's yeah yeah and and
the fact that you can exhale onto a
mirror and it will fog the mirror it
means there's moisture coming out of
your breath
you're dodging the are these people
drinking their pee question
so no so totally drinking the peas
totally drinking the pea so for star
talk just recently i interviewed two
international space station astronauts
while while they were on board and you
may recognize their names jessica meer
and christina cook
they they made headlines for being the
first team female team to space walk
together and
we chatted about food in space let's
check it out
for long-term space
travel
obviously there'll be some expectation
that you grow your own food and is there
how close are we to growing all of your
own food without requiring sort of
supply chains either to and from the
space station or to and from mars if
that's our ultimate destination
absolutely great question i think that
right now we're at a place where we're
learning the best you know ways that we
can grow things in space but where we're
really looking to go is to develop
systems that are one closed-loop system
so a system where we're using waste
products from various sources and
feeding those in to the
actual plant development and that can
include our carbon dioxide cycle our
oxygen cycle and our water cycle and we
actually have some really neat life
support systems on board right now that
are testing some of those technologies
another aspect of the food system that
really has to grow would be
incorporating proteins right now we have
lettuce as our main you know crop that
we've grown we've grown different things
up here they've grown flowers we're
looking into starting into vegetables
and fruits but incorporating protein
sources like peanuts or maybe legumes i
think is the next sort of big leap we're
not quite there yet um as jessica
mentioned we've had salad and we joke
sometimes that the caloric
intake that it's that we've used so far
in growing it might be a little bit more
than what we end up consuming but
obviously the techniques are what's
important and proving out the systems
and the operational concept
i'm guessing that you're not going to
any time soon
start traveling with farm animals so
likely all of your protein will come
from plant-based sources which would
mean the future of space exploration
would be vegetarian that's what that
sounds like
maybe we're not sure you know we also do
have some other devices that are pretty
exciting up here right now we have uh
one facility called the biofabrication
facility which is actually the goal of
that is to heart to grow human organs in
space now that's of course not for food
or consumption that is to contribute to
the deficit of organ for transplant
operations on the ground
by any kinds of efforts on the ground
when you are trying to produce these
tissues and make these bioartificial
tissues there are some problems with the
support structure for these and so the
theory is that in microgravity we won't
have that problem with the support
structure so we can better grow these
bioartificial tissues and then turn them
into complete organs going a little bit
along with that with 3d printing we have
other 3d printers up here to make other
pieces of hardware the russians also
recently tested some animal cells so
some animal protein cells to see whether
or not they could 3d print meat so there
are some experiments that are trending
in that direction as well okay i i don't
know why i didn't think of that of
course if you can lab grow proteins uh
meat proteins then you never needed the
animal in the first place and then
there's another source of protein for
you well excellent guys thanks for
taking the time for star talk radio and
we got you on video as well and so very
much appreciated this thank you very
much thank you neil it was our pleasure
station this is houston acr that
concludes our event as we count down to
20 continuous years of humans living and
working on the international space
station
[Applause]
i gotta
interject when the movie gravity came
out i posted a series of tweets
that commented on things they missed
like sandra bullock's
bangs always pointed downwards
and i said am i being harsh and i said
anytime you see anybody in zero g the
hair is going wild and so i wanted to
see wild bangs on sandra bullock and we
did not everything else was zero g
except her hair i just wanted to
let the record show um jenny so grace
what are the capabilities
[Laughter]
what's in your mouth spit that out it
was pretty good yeah i know i said it
smelled good but i tasted it
it's good it smelled good it just
smelled really spicy eat the beer it's
really it's really spicy
which you find that most people really
do appreciate
on station right there are a lot of that
like pepper chili it's not all true but
a lot now if you're not if you're not
necessarily a proponent of the fluid in
the head theory that everybody up there
is like they've got a cold what do you
attribute this this desire for spicier
food
well
that also is just i mean not every crew
looks for spicy food and some of that
might be because they're just eating
pre-packaged foods the entire time
they're up there and they're not cooking
and things like that so that does
provide differences in flavor condiments
is one of the only ways that they have
to customize their own foods and people
are bringing up their own hot sauce
bottle
they let you do that
because it's not like a giant glob of
sriracha floating through the the cabin
would be a problem
you know i mean
they do get sriracha they do get started
but do they get in like a little bitty
package they don't get like a box don't
touch your body
yeah they do they get a bottle they get
an actual how do you get it
how does that work so well they send
condiments and they have a little fridge
up there now
the sriracha the um
well it has a certain surface tension so
that's how they eat as well so
everything has a certain surface tension
and if you put it on your food and it
has that surface tension it stays it
stays just like it'll stay on a spoon or
a fork while you're eating it or in the
past like pudding has very high surface
tension
yeah
oh no do we need to call that why yes i
had
the russians are 3d printing meat next
door
that was just an offhanded comment oh
yeah and also so great what are the
actual food capabilities on iss right
now
for daily food consumption it's
pre-packaged food where they add water
or they heat it no manufacturing i'm
talking and then as far as so that you
saw that they grew some salad in the
veggie and that's it as far as foods
that they're actually eating will 3d
printing be something that i mean
because a lot of people think that's
going to be an answer we've got an image
of them harvesting mustard greens let's
see if we have what we have up there my
mustard greens don't look like that
okay yeah but if i'm in space somehow
i'm not thinking gee i i hunger for
mustard greens
no you want pizza
[Laughter]
so so tell me if as they said growing
the salad takes more energy than the
energy it then provides to you
what hope is there that this would ever
work
well they mentioned that this is proving
out the systems at this point and that's
true because if we're ever going to
become earth independent and move
towards those systems you have to show
that they work and it is very
challenging to water uh crops in space
flight so we proved them out with the
easiest systems which are salad crops
and so next they're planning on growing
tomatoes in space and so that requires
artificial pollination so there are a
lot of things that you have to prove
that you can do and actually
swarms of bees into the space station
what could go wrong
[Laughter]
so i want both of your opinions about
the future of lab-grown meat as a
solution to the protein challenge in
space are you cool with
alton are you cool lab lab grown meat
i'm cool with it as a concept i just
don't know why we need it i i don't i
don't crave
i think we've got to get to a point to
where we're like okay well we don't
crave meat so much that we're willing to
put this much energy into simply making
an analog of it why not just make
something delicious out of the things
that we have that are renewable and that
makes sense
and you know one of the issues now with
with meat analogues is that um we're
going to 80 people agreed with you i
know yeah okay
the other day but they were the cool
ones um
one of one of the issues i think we're
going to get into with meat replacement
is that it's all based on pea protein
essentially there's a lot of p protein
involved and
you know that just means that we're
shifting no no that's meat substitute
not not talking about absolutely
yeah yeah i am talking about i was
growing meat proteins i don't
growing organs for transplant is one
thing i don't know that we need to grow
meat i i i don't i guess we've got to
forget where you got to do it but i
don't know that i think it's necessary
grace where are you
i think that
uh looking at all of these options as
you know we have a growing population we
have a lot of challenges here on earth
we have challenges in space flight with
resources as well looking at options and
seeing if they can become feasible is
definitely worthwhile across the board
because we have a lot looking at all
options right looking at all options
there are still a lot of challenges with
lab grown meat that would need to be
solved before that can become a viable
option
plus you need to do the trade studies to
see
is this actually saving you anything
because there's a lot of processing
going into those things
but looking at all the options is
necessary because we have a growing
population because we have resource
limitations on earth and that's very
true in space flight too
one of the challenges in space flight
that's a little bit unique
especially with exploration missions
where we only have a few crew is that
they would have to
do the process themselves so any process
that we think could be a solution
it would have to be a solution from the
beginning of producing it all the way to
the point of consumption because
if an astronaut has to
actually participate in that process i
don't know maybe some people like to go
home and do a science experiment and
then eat that science experiment after
after they worked for a whole day right
but
in general we like to look at things for
exploration especially as what are you
willing to do in your own kitchen
and if some of these solutions can
become resource viable for exploration
meaning they use less resources than a
pre-packaged system or perhaps you could
find in situ resource utilization
on a planetary surface um there's people
so in isru very big concept in nasa
right where
you go there not bringing supplies with
you you go there look for the supplies
that you would then use in situ right
while you're the isru yeah very big
concept in nasa sorry
so yes and and you know there's groups
that are looking at
taking the the um
uh carbon dioxide and using the carbon
in that as a source for so many other
things and if you start using that as a
as a feed source instead of having to
take sugar or things like that once we
start overcoming these challenges
there's going to be new things that open
up but it is easier on earth because
those would be somebody's job and we go
to the grocery store and we buy a
finished product for the crew
if they have to participate in that
product in that
in that production in any way it has to
be incredibly acceptable something that
we would want to do here on earth
because or you one of the astronauts
sole job would be to be the chef
so alton if we it's mushrooms again
tonight kids
well alton it's there's got to be some
interesting future in lab-grown meat
proteins because then you could
molecularize it and put in one of your
own unique sort of flavor flavored
i'd be more interested though in coming
up with various pastes that you could
print though i mean like krill or some
other animal that has a huge bio payoff
as far as it's it's a feed to body
weight ratio and then taking that and
turning that into like okay i'm going to
take this cup of water and i'm going to
grow blah blah krill in it sea monkeys
and then i'm going to
grind them up in this machine and i'm
going to print a hamburger out of it
to me it's like if we if we can take
think of things that already grow that
are already you know life forms that we
know that we can take advantage of they
don't care that much about gravity maybe
they grow on water whatever they're
bacterias that produce for instance uh
we talk a lot about umami as chefs you
know there are bacteria that grow
glutamates and glutamic acid can
actually come off the bacteria if all
that could go into your little printer
kit you could just say what do you want
tonight well i'll have that hot dog but
recent research that shows that a very
efficient
uh um even sustainable source of protein
is rodents yes so what absolutely what's
the new york city
we've got so our rodents eat pizza by
the way just so you know
we've all seen the video now yes the
pizza rat
um so so
so great is there any talk at nasa about
breeding rodents for protein for
long-term missions well actually they
can be a good source of vitamin c
so no scurvy
i'll yay the scurvy
so is it happening space rats
what so what i would say about any sort
of animals um you'd still be thinking of
you have people i'm not talking about
any animals i'm talking about rodents
but this is still true for rodents so it
would be true for anything as soon as
you start having a group of explorers
who are intended to go out and explore
the martian surface and then they come
back what are you willing to do in your
own kitchen and if you start having
things like rodents is that really
something that we find acceptable is it
something they would find acceptable
because we're trying to promote high
performance we want them to be at their
top physical peak at their top cognitive
peak so we want to give them foods that
they really want to eat
and then there's also an interesting um
thought that
that could be the only other life form
they're interacting with and you know
there's cases where if you become really
attached to that i saw that movie it's
called not gonna eat willard
yeah
have you thought about maybe a mind
experiment where like okay they're going
to mars they're not going to want to eat
rats but they don't get any kind of
outside information except for the stuff
that we give them so we create some sort
of television shows where the reality
back on earth is where sunday is very
cool to eat rats and now everybody's
eating ramen and jennifer hansen loves
rats he eats rats and over the time
they're traveling for months and months
and they're like this seems to be the
new cool thing i don't know maybe this
is something i could try and then other
eating the heads off rats none the wiser
has nasa thought of that where did that
come from jordan
you can create it's a propaganda machine
that's what a spaceship is
so after you've gone out on the surface
of mars you want to come back and have a
big juicy steak is what you're saying
or a really nice salad
no nobody comes back from the service to
mars
[Laughter]
it's just not not even the vegetarians
no no they want they want a steak too
we got to end this segment coming up on
the next segment we're going to actually
talk about the sustainability of food on
earth when start talk continues at town
hall live
welcome back to star talk live
from town hall
new york city
we're talking about
food
in space and on earth i've got alton
brown
in the house
thank you
he's a patron saint of food geeks
we've
we also have grace douglas dr grace
douglas from nasa houston
jordan pepper
so we talked about molecular gastronomy
in space and now let's talk about the
future of food on earth
so
both of you i want to ask by the way
when i look to nasa i look at nasa
solving problems we didn't even know
needed solved and then you learn that
they actually have application back here
on earth so when you look at the
challenges alton um we have
overpopulation that's going to be a
thing
if it's not a problem now it will be
soon we've got climate change
restructuring where things are grown and
where they're not grown are the
honeybees what's the what's i want an
update on them i i don't know what that
ain't good
and overfishing
so
all these problems on earth so i want to
ask you
where is this headed and then grace i
want to know
can you foresee any of the challenges of
the mars food problem
actually having an application back here
on earth so alton
where are we overpopulation are we going
to be able to feed
10 billion 20 billion people
yes eat more people
i saw that movie uh soylent green is
obviously the answer but i think it can
be done with a more culinary uh flair
okay
um
we have to diversify
our our our pallets we have to diversify
um our food supply system one of the
issues that we've run into in the united
states is um that we went to centralized
uh farming and in centralized processing
in this country after world war ii um
and we we we transport things great
distances instead of making things very
locally and and the result of that is
that we end up
having all of a sudden maybe 70 people
in six states get sick from something
from lettuce
right which really shouldn't be
happening um but that but that's because
we've got a food system that is based on
giving everybody everything all the time
we're certainly giving people things out
of season
and things that require massive amounts
of resources to grow massive amounts of
water uh massive amounts of land
certainly in the case uh with with with
most cattle and other land-based animals
uh what we're gonna have to face the
fact of is that so far we have not
managed things terribly well
uh we have not managed things terribly
well the oceans uh certainly um are our
case in point so i think what we're
going to have to do and this is going to
be very difficult because it does
require
some international cooperation is that
we've got to re-examine the viability of
what local farming looks like and and
one of the ways that that i feel hopeful
about is the idea of vertical farming in
the ocean
which is that we can take a a patch of
sea maybe a mile offshore of some place
like northern california and that we can
farm it from the surface all the way to
the floor in a way that is sustainable
in a way that is also beneficial to the
surrounding ecosystem so we're talking
about growing filter feeders uh like
like mussels that grow on ropes or
oysters on the bed growing a lot of kelp
and and also harvesting the animals that
live inside that kelp in such a way that
these kind of microfarms can create a
lot of protein
and a lot of nutrition while being
sustainably managed um and that's a long
answer uh but i do think that what it's
going to take in the long run is we've
got to vary what we eat um and we we've
got to decentralize our our food
processing do you see any grace you see
any anything lined up with what you're
doing in houston that could actually
benefit any of this
i would say that a lot of the goals of
nasa are similar to the goals in the
world we need to find things that are
going to grow in very harsh environments
and not even necessarily um you know
that they're going to be outside but the
fact that you have to limit the water
that you're using that you have to find
stuff that's going to be very resilient
and crops that can
just keep growing in those environments
um in very small confined spaces as well
so um you know your idea of vertical
farming and and having some of the more
sensitive crops even be grown in that
sort of
method so that you can really control it
and produce more food and control where
it's going
is definitely
an advantage of those areas and
definitely things that we'd have to look
about look at if we're going to solve
the world food problem i think that
there's a lot of other things
that are out there that are being
developed that might we might start
seeing in the next couple years too um
just in relation to things like the lab
grown meat and things like that so we
need to be exploring all the options um
and
for nasa the real goal is
how do we miniaturize that and how do we
reduce the resources
so
to such a low level that we can actually
put it on a space mission because it's
very one of the biggest challenges we
always have with food which weighs so
much is we have to reduce the mass and
reduce the volume so anything that we
send to make food has to have reduced
mass and reduced volume the other thing
is anything we send with food has to
have a five year shelf life if it's
going to mars any of the reagents that
you're using with it seeds would have to
have a five year shelf life in the
radiation environment so we have a
storage
concern there too and that could be
something that might also become more
interesting on earth as time goes on so
i think the idea that our resources are
limited and we have to find those
solutions
we tend to work with industry and with
academia to find those solutions and
that's just not an island in the middle
of the country exactly yes
so alton are you have you seen effects
of the climate shift in
what your tasks are in the kitchen the
availability of some foods relative to
others or the cost absolutely a really
great example
of something that's going on right now
that folks here might not even know
about is that sugar prices are about to
uh go
up quite a bit uh here in the united
states um in this past year last two
years the sugar beet crop failed in a
good bit of the upper midwest midwest
due to weather conditions that have been
attributed to global warming this means
that we are not going to be able to
produce enough sugar and are going to
have to now import it but our
governmental systems are set up
specifically to place very high tariffs
on foreign sugar because we wanted to
keep our own sugar prices at a certain
level and now for a lot of farmers crops
not just the sugar it's not but the big
thing right now though is coming into
the holidays major industrial bakers are
getting uh forced measure notices from
the growers basically saying yeah sorry
about that not having any sugar
because they're so now we're having to
say holy holy moly we've been
self-supporting since world since the
30s and in sugar and now we we cannot
provide enough sugar
for for our industry but there's a flip
side of that like for example it's a
little bit warmer in england now and
last i checked they're growing wine
there's champagne coming out of england
and they're like boasting of it have you
had any of it yet no yeah well
[Laughter]
my family's from michigan and they claim
that michigan will be wine country by
2070.
i'm hoping that's the case because i
bought a significant amount of property
when you start looking at you know it in
major growing areas where something is
very special i mean
you know you joke or we're joking about
champagne well i mean
of course because champagne's only grown
in champagne but i'm talking about that
champagne when you're talking about
those kinds of micro products like in
france yes very very few degrees of
change a little bit
and rainfall
um is going to completely knock that out
so i i think that the microphone defined
the product in the first place it did
the terroir the microclimate the hill
that hit this side of the uh sorry the
sun hit this side of the hill that had
this much chalk in it so this much
radiation was you know went back yeah
it's all about that micro tarawa and
those microclimates well those are now
changing whether we want to admit it or
not they are and so that is going to
change the products that are available
so the best jam freaking pain in the
world might be coming out of detroit any
minute
getting the property now it could happen
so i mean it is not it's not incredible
tell me about the bees
these are in um horrible shape bees in
space actually really like that idea um
because um you know bees are the major
pollinator of uh food crops in the
united states and actually in most of
the world and due to some chemicals
that um we have used on our crops the
bee population is falling at an alarming
rate and when that drops to a particular
level it will simply be impossible
to fertilize certain plants you know
most most of the crops in the united
states are pollinated by bees during
that season guys drive around and girls
flatbed trucks full of beehives park in
the field wait a few days and then drive
off and those bees provide the
pollination services and so every flower
that gets pollinated uh some kind of
fruit came out of that flower exactly
this is the whole that's the process so
any for just the cross yeah the cross
pollination of male or female plants
trees it doesn't matter what it is right
right right and we're losing we're
losing colonies at a at a horrible rate
and i i hate to say that uh there there
have been some uh some some laws and
legal shenanigans uh even just this year
that have perhaps made it harder to to
uh protect them which is so concerning
could the future of molecular gastronomy
find
scientific chemical solutions to some of
these problems that global climate
change is bringing upon us i will tell
you that i know for a fact to preserve
some of what we don't know about i don't
know about that but i do know that there
is one uh very very very um highly
respected technical university on the
east coast that is working on robot bees
i saw that episode of dark mirror i'm
telling you though
these are actually happening uh we will
have micro robotic pollinators for
specific plants and they will be sold to
us by monsanto just you watch
um but but talking about the specific
you know will i think that if if cooks
whether it's molecular gastronomy or or
whatever
chefs as influencers cooks as
influencers
we we do play a very significant role in
this because we help figure out things
for people to eat and then make them
popular and and right now in the last 20
years that has really been the
globalization
of ingredients uh which has massively
been the result of of one thing the
internet and specifically
amazon uh
love it or hate it transportation yeah
love it or hate it makes it possible for
anybody to have anything any darn time
they want um if i was doing a startup
right now we would be figuring out how
to farm out of amazon boxes
all right i'm going to turn amazon boxes
into a farm uh
a way of doing that so if farming as we
know
uh large animal farming is hugely
consumptive of water and land and
resources and the like so
there's the stuff that tastes like meat
but is vegetable based what's it called
um well there's impossible burger and
beef uh beyond meat beyond meat right so
uh has nasa considered beyond meat as a
just to to keep the flavor spectrum
broad for those in space
so our foods right now actually we do
send quite a few meats so we can send
real meats prepackaged and they do last
for several years to the crew so right
now that would probably not be a
solution because you just be replacing
the meat with that burger for a few
people um and
in general most people in this country
even are still
omnivores so there are very it's a small
percentage of the population that's
vegan and vegetarian so we support what
the crews generally want to eat so that
we can
you know keep them eating however you
know as you as you go forward in this
area and get to a point where we're
having colonization and people have
specialized jobs and now you are growing
crops potentially that would be a
solution there where that somebody's job
is to make um that that sort of burger
that way so it it could potentially
happen um we don't really know what the
future of space food's going to look
like so it's wide open and it's really
what what can the solution be
and can you get the resources down to
enable that solution there's actually a
lot of resources that go into making
those burgers did you visit one of those
did you visit one of those plants i have
yes and what was your reaction wow
that's a lot of pea protein
that's a lot of pea protein that was
your reaction
that is most of what is going in there
but it's got a longer shelf life than
meat well not if it's in one of these
right i mean meat
can be several years it doesn't matter
uh first okay for a package like this
and if it's radiated so that you kill
all the bacteria or just um
thermostabilized like canned food do you
get to meet the pea protein do you get
the pet the pea protein i named it
if you guys knew that for instance okay
we can make a burger out of mushrooms
and we can grow mushrooms in space
because mushrooms like it dark they like
it moist they like you know then knowing
how to do that would be would be a
benefit right because you can extract
protein from them it's a lot easier than
raising a cow in space um or
why are you killing me like that that
would be certainly true no it's like are
you guys doing that maybe she's like
anything would be easier than raising a
cow in space it's my guess
i'm just that's i'm just spitballing
here i think raising a wolverine could
you raise it in space
pigs in space would be very very
difficult
but mushrooms and other things that have
a considerable amount of glutamates and
other proteins
might might not be um
anyway so how do we balance the two of
you i ask how do we how do we think
about the relationship between our
investment in space colonization and
whatever secondary benefits we might
derive from it and our investments in
the earth environment
do you see a place a connection between
those two or are you going to have to
fight
with the environmentalists because they
want the resources just to fix things on
earth
is there some
part of your job that says no some of
this could really help on the other side
of this this research chain right and i
think that's true across nasa
a lot of the things that we're doing and
the fact that we're trying everything we
make we have to figure out how to do it
with less resources and so in the end a
lot of that technology even you know
when working with industry and working
with academia and working directly at
nasa
is going to have ways that it can
transfer
to
the world today because we are always
pushing to get better at doing that now
i've said multiple times that i think
the world's first trillionaire
is the person who figures out how to
exploit the resources on asteroids and
comets
so is nasa thinking about that
creatively as part of the in-situ
resource utilization space has unlimited
resources basically it's just you just
need access to it or are you still just
worried about what you bring and what
you might be able to grow on on the spot
those kinds of
investigations are going on together so
in the beginning we probably will have
to bring a lot more but eventually the
goal would be
self-sustainability and earth
independence and to get there you need
to be looking at these other things and
proving them out because it's a huge
jump to go to that and we need to show
on the lunar surface and then on the
mars surface that these things are
working and we can depend on them
because the worst thing that could
happen is you're depending on your food
growing and then it doesn't grow so you
want to make sure that you have food
just add poop and it grows just fine
yes we learned that on mars
the poop potatoes
yes
can we talk about the martian now can we
talk about it
but but aren't the things that you're
you're talking about i mean that's
basically life on earth and a microcosm
limited resources limited space limited
energy
and we're out in the middle of space all
freaking alone so
it's kind of the same thing
so nasa save us
except alton you can breathe the air
here that's you know well now
today
so nasa is famous for how visible its
achievements are relative to its budget
you know and i used to joke that
how much you know people say why are we
spending money in space and not on earth
how much do you think they're getting in
space of it as a fraction of the tax
dollar they'll come up with 10 15 and
then i tell them no it's four tenths of
one cent
and they so i keep thinking nasa should
get the budget that people think they're
getting
that would be amazing right
so
so it's a testament to how visible
nasa's achievements are because people
think its budget is much greater than it
is given that fact uh what are some of
the future plans
to
[Music]
for education or
uh
i've read something about participation
crowdsourcing some of the future nasa
projects what can you tell us about that
uh so we are actually in this area in
the food area um
we're exploring uh releasing a challenge
to the public to academia and industry
to help us with these food challenges
because
right so they would challenge it would
be incentivized challenges we're looking
at a centennial challenge with cash
prizes thank you and um
[Laughter]
and so basically the goal is we need
safe acceptable and nutritious food that
reduces resource use on these
long-duration missions and we don't have
a food system that can do that right now
and
we are investigating a lot of the
technologies that already exist but
we're always looking for new
technologies what is the next cutting
edge going to be so we're looking at
releasing this challenge to the public
sometime next year and
trying to get
to provide those incentives
and these kinds of challenges can also
help um you know
create the next generation of scientists
and the next generation generation of
engineers and keep
nasa and the united states as a leader
in science technology is there a hashtag
or twitter i mean what
how is this getting out there so it is
um if if you watch the website nasa.gov
slash solve
you'll be able to see when this
challenge is released oh okay it's a
smart idea if there's one thing
america's like it's doing a food contest
and getting money
you might be able just give him a big
t-shirt ultimate baking space
challenge and now and now
rub space
well has nasa ever done that before yes
nasa does these challenges um in
different areas what came out of the
last one do you go off top of your head
they did a 3d printing of houses um
and that one had some pretty interesting
you know looking at 3d printing your
habitats right and 3d printing of houses
can actually have a lot of applications
and got it so the real value here is
like the x prize is if you put up a cash
prize for the winner
that
the people who compete are all putting
up their own money to compete for that
cash prize
so what you're really getting is the sum
of everyone's investment
as a
r and d magnifier on what the final
product will become
it's an extraordinary system that
actually works
and there are some cases where the
people will spend more money
than what the prize will be
just to win and then they get the
visibility and the fame and the and the
and and the attention so
uh so i i wish you luck on this uh you
and nasa then it's not luck i wish you
um
all the innovation that you deserve and
that comes your way
so we need to land this plane
sorry we need to land this rocket um
is there uh just
alton do you have any sort of parting
thoughts for us
um
yeah i think that by the way you have a
resting grumpy face i just wanted you to
know
if if no one told you that i want to
tell you it's because i ate those beans
the beans were very very good um i think
that um if i was going to have anything
uh here to wrap up it's that everybody
needs to pay a heck of a lot of
attention to what they put in their pie
hole
we need to be very watchful of what
we're doing we need to be more aware of
where it's coming from who's growing it
how far it's being shipped and what kind
of resources go into it
that means we're going to have to do a
lot more work we have to do more due
diligence about what we eat
because it has a very very specific and
direct
effect on on what kind of resources
we're going to have to work with to win
x prizes with or to colonize the rest of
space with we do have to maintain home
and we need to be better at it
dr grace
any any parting thoughts for us this
evening
well i think it's pretty incredible that
um we've had crew living
in space flight consecutively now for
almost 20 years
and one of the things that we do know is
that they all want to eat something
different and food is incredibly
important
so
it's definitely something we need to
consider as our challenges
for resources
and our shelf life uh requirements
become longer uh we really need to
consider how are we gonna solve this in
a way where we're supporting our cruise
health and performance um because in the
end you know as humans we like to
explore and
what we're doing at nasa is really what
we're doing as a
as a country so this you know this is
for all of us and what comes out of this
is going to benefit all of us
cool thank you for that
jordan jordan after your rodent eating
recitation moments ago i'm a little
afraid to ask your final thoughts neil
don't don't fear me
you know i was moved today i think uh i
will watch the things i put in my mouth
i think that is a good thing to to walk
away
from this with uh i've been part of the
reason some of the things we've talked
about in the past is sort of my love of
nasa and uh american ingenuity and i
think one of your documentaries was we
covered nasa and whether or not we're
gonna go to mars and like how you can
invest in something like that and uh the
the the byproduct of that can be so good
for a culture like us and so uh it's
good to be a part of conversations like
this because it gives me optimism i
think if we could put a man on the moon
and if we can call the number one
restaurant in the world a restaurant
that serves ant paste then i kind of
think we could maybe attack some of
these problems we talked about there's
no visit
exactly no excellent thank you jordan
but so jordan i i think i'm a little
older than you so my generation says if
we can put on man on the moon we can do
anything you're saying if we can make
lemon paste out of ants we can do
anything i think so that's that's that's
a lower bar i think well i think my
generation that's where we set our bars
[Laughter]
can i talk about politics now no no
we're good we're good
nope we're good
um
uh if i can offer some reflections on
this evening first i i was immensely
enlightened by all that each of you
contributed um as well as ariel johnson
earlier and
it's interesting when you look at sort
of the history of human conflict
apart from religious wars and political
wars
one of the sources of conflict was
access to resources
sometimes those resources are water
sometimes it's food
arable land
and
so much of what we discussed regarding
food
is not
food that separates us
it's food that brings us together
the fact that the different countries on
the international space station that's
what the i stands for it's international
we'll come together
and share food
because we're all human and we all eat
multiple times a day
so that this
this
fact
which we have turned into ritual
and ritual is such a fundamental part of
what it is to be human
i'm wondering
whether our shared challenge of making
sure earth does not die under our feet
because if earth dies under our feet it
doesn't affect just one country and not
another it affects everybody
that's why we call it global climate
change we're all in this together
so
i
i'm imagining a future
where
maybe
there are no wars
because our survival depends on each
other
and we being
shepherds
of the earth to nourish civilization
going forward
and in that future
every country
is around a table
sharing food prepared
from all over the globe
and that would be sort of
my vision
of
eternal peace
in this world
thank you all
thank you
jordan kepler thank you
ariel johnson in the back
grace juggler
everybody's ariel come on out erio
alton brown
i've been your host neil degrasse tyson
you're a personal astrophysicist
and as always from star talk we bid you
to keep looking up thank you thank you
for the power
wow